there are many great books out there for
any entrepreneur to read in general but
I chose 10 specific books for young or
teenage entrepreneurs to read and I
chose 10 different subjects and topics
for you to read and study before you
become an entrepreneur or if you're on
already the journey of becoming an
entrepreneur so with that being said the
ten topics will be very simple clarity
economy enemy your inspiration strategy
plain hurt long-term thinking discipline
system and being duplicatable and
innovation so with that being said let's
get right into a number 10 the book is
by Peter Drucker its title is innovation
and entrepreneurship and Peter Drucker
in general you've got a lot of great
books for you to read if you study Peter
Drucker you will learn a ton about
hiring firing marketing strategy
advertising I don't agree with
everything he believes in but he's got a
lot of great things that will make you
think and get creative about what is the
formula to be an innovative or creative
all this other stuff that different
people have used in the past he covers
that in the book innovation and
entrepreneurship number nine is a book
on system and duplicatable let me tell
you why I think it's very important for
teenage or young entrepreneurs to read a
book on this and that book is made in
America it's the story of Sam Walton the
reason why I love Sam Walton the most
when I talk to a young or teenage
entrepreneur the reason why I think is
the best book for you to read or study
best person to study here's a guy named
Sam Walton there was nothing special
about him in 1962 it was the year of the
super discount stores that's when Kmart
was founded Walmart was found at Target
all of these guys all got started in
1962 and Sam Walton you stole one of
these Franklin stores and then he
started Walmart in the first five years
Kmart opens up 250 stores and Walmart
only opens up nine stores fast forward
today came outside of business Walmart's
got 2.2 employees worldwide and his four
kids got four kids each of them are
worked a minimum of 40 billion dollars
today if he was alive today he
one sixty two and a half times the bill
gates so you want to study a San Walter
because nothing was special about the
guy he's not somebody where you may
study someone in that guy's an absolute
genius Sam Walton was a simple guy who
was a hard worker and he always looked
for ways to make his business better so
made in America for me will be number
nine on the list I almost thought if I
put them on top five but it's number
nine on the list with system
duplicatable now number eight discipline
for discipline I chose Lean Startup lean
startup teaches you when you're younger
and you're just looking at this and say
wow I can't believe I can only get some
money for my mom my dad some investor
some venture capital angel that gives me
quarter million dollars I can start my
own business and you haven't yet tasted
the idea of making your money if you
truly are an entrepreneur watching this
and you're 13 I guarantee you've made
some kind of money your sole cooking
shirts something you've sold if you're
blood if you're one of these folks
that's an absolute entrepreneur since
you were kid you probably already saw
something if you're someone that's going
to be an accidental entrepreneur from
watching something like this then you
become inspired by it you got to learn
some of those concepts of making the
money and how to stay lean so you can
turn this $200 into $400 and money is
all about doubling your money so I can
make this phone into eight hundred eight
hundred sixty ninety six hundred thirty
two sixty four twelve thousand
twenty-five thousand fifty thousand
hundred thousand two hundred four
hundred million dollars that's a lean
startup it teaches you how to stay very
disciplined number seven on the list
long-term thinking is they think that a
lot of young and Tina Johnson especially
today you need I'll say why today seen
many many years ago when there was no
social media YouTube or Instagram or
snapchat people weren't as much in a
hurry or impatient as they are today so
the for discipline for long term
thinking I chose snowball by Warren
Buffett because even though Warren
Buffett today is worth sixty seventy
billion dollars at 52 he was only worth
fifty million dollars now you may say 50
million is a lot of money not compared
to sixty billion dollars so he went from
52 years old at 50mm
so now having 60 billion dollars it
requires a lot of long-term thinking I
think one of the best places I want to I
went to Venice Italy and I went to this
one Chapel one-one-one Church I went to
that was 330 years old and when you're
reading the story of it it took 80 years
to build and a man who designed this
thing to build he knew he was 50 years
old what he wrote up he's never going to
see the final product and most likely
his kids are never going to see the
final product
the only people are going to see the
final product with his grandkids when
you study Warren Buffett you will learn
about long-term thinking where it may be
helping you some of the decisions you
make that's about hurry and honey and
honey and hurry hurry
you become aggressively patient you're
still aggressive but your patient for
your business to be built it's a very
important concept to pick up as a young
teenage entrepreneur nah man I plain
hurt
I chose obstacle is the way obstacle is
the way which is a great book by Ryan
holiday in this book he explains to you
the concept of stoicism and stoicism is
a philosophy that was born from cynicism
a lot of times we call people cynic the
word cynic comes from cynicism cynicism
used to be a philosophy of people who
would sit on and they would say nothing
that's going to happen if your wife's
going to leave you are czar she's going
to leave you if you get sick odds are
you are going to die everything was
cynical so they had this philosophy
cynicism and one of the members of
cynicism was a guy named Seneca he said
I just can't listen to this crap anymore
and he started stoicism and the first
major leader in the world that picked up
stoicism it took a toll different level
was Marcus Aurelius who wrote the book
meditations he took stoicism to a whole
different level and he ran Rome he was
the Emperor for seven years he was loved
adored everybody loved this guy Marcus
Aurelius and Ryan Holliday takes that
concept of stoicism and explains it in
today's world of business and he
explains you that challenges are going
to happen but obstacle is do I think a
lot of times a young or teenage
entrepreneur the moment you face one
challenge or one issue that comes up
people get you know too distracted oh
it's not for me I can do it which in
reality
tickle is never going to stop the moment
you identified then you know that's a
part of life
you will look at obstacles in a complete
different way so ryan holidays were
playing obstacles the wave number six
number five strategy for a 14-year old
you'll look at everything and you look
at it from a different lens than a 38
year old looks at or even a 68 year old
or even a 24 year old you're looking at
it from a complete different lens
because your generation is changing so
quickly with everything
snap changes everything Instagram
changed everything Facebook Twitter
YouTube everything should you have a lot
more access to content today I didn't
grow up watching games on an iPad my
kids do I didn't grow up with any of
this stuff I went to school we have to
go to a library to do research on
something with newspaper today you
Google I didn't go to high school with
Google ever being around for me we
didn't experience experience Google
myself we had a long chat that came out
late in senior year of my high school so
when I went into the army I still listen
to a Walkman when I got out of the army
with the first time I listened to CDs
and then most of you don't even know
what a CD looks like or a Walkman looks
like life that's what we experienced so
for strategy blue ocean strategy it's
going to help your mind think about ways
of doing business better that may be a
millennial or a Gen X may not even think
about you're going to seek in from a
complete different lens so if you can
get the strategy down on how it's done
you'll have an edge on everybody also
blue ocean strategy a phenomenal book
for you to read I put that as number
four number five inspiration it's Elon
Musk the book is called Elon Musk it's
written by an author who chased them
down and said you're either going to let
me come and interview you or if you
don't I'm gonna write you based on what
other people say about you versus I can
come and interview you and I can tell
you what other people told me about you
and then you can verify to give me your
story of the version and also both
stories and Elon agree so she went
interview I mean the author went
interviewed they wrote this book the
phenomenal book good that of me and you
see how this kid was grown how he was
raised and how we view things of what
books he read growing up and why he was
so turned on by certain things and who
was his uncle his father his parents and
what kind of an impact dad made in a way
was raised just a very good book to read
as a source of inspiration for you
number three enemy you need to know your
enemy very very early on and the book
I'm gonna recommend on enemy is called
outwitting the devil outwitting the
devil was a book written by Napoleon
Hill I want to say 1929 1930s that he
didn't publish at that time in years
later the book was published by a lady
named Sharon Lechter I think it's Sharon
Lechter that the book was published by
and the first time I read this book I'm
gonna take a funny story I read this
book literally at the bar of PF Changs
on my iPad the book has just come out
couple weeks prior to that I sat there
and I read the book in one city because
I couldn't get up I couldn't get up I
call that I said I got to finish this
book and I finished the book one by one
by when I was going through it I said
everybody needs to read this book
especially the younger generation so
outwitting the devil will be our
number-one enemy you got to read that
that'll be the number three book number
two economy and I was kind of conflicted
on what book to recommend on the economy
I think the best book that I can
recommend you on economy is not going to
say like here goli capitalism socialism
communism and realize what it is to hire
this person fire this person why you
gotta let go of this person why you
wanna stuff you with this why do some
people become wealthy some don't why do
some countries produce more successful
people than other people why do certain
philosophies work in don't work so the
book I recommended here for you to read
as the economy for economy is by Ayn
Rand
it's called Atlas Shrugged Atlas
Shrugged now there's two ways you can do
it you can actually read the book it's a
big book and it'll change the way you
view everything in life it's a big book
if you read it and if you don't want to
read it you can listen to it there's an
audio version of it as well but
regardless it will change the way you
view every single thing you're going to
think about John Gulf in a different way
you're going to look at the economy a
different way you're going to look at
the people you work with the friends
family parents teachers you're going to
look at everything in a complete
different lens when you read this book
on Atlas Shrugged she wrote two books
Fountainhead and Atlas Shrugged I
recommend Atlas Shrugged / Fountainhead
and number one is clarity and I was I
was
dating on which book to read put this
for clarity and I the reason why I think
clarity I put number one is because when
you're in school and you don't really
know what you want out of life and
everybody is telling you how you need to
live you need to go to college get a
degree because if you get this doubt
that you'll be successful if you need to
go out and do this and do this and
you're still you're still gullible and
uh poor naive enough where somebody else
can persuade you otherwise so what I'm
going to recommend you is complete 180
of what everybody else is going to
recommend you and I'm doing that
intentionally I'm telling you this in
advance in case you choose to share this
video with your parents which is even a
better idea I'm intentionally wanted to
give you the complete opposite argue
because I know you're not hearing it for
you to get clarity see it's if if you're
raised in a family where everybody is
teaching you capitalism all the time I
want you to study socialism and
communism to know you know the opposite
if you're in a family that's raised
communism or socialism all the time and
everybody's a Democrat I need you to
study the complete opposite side because
I won't complete opposite argument for
me to see both sides I like that I want
to see the complete up if I'm born in a
family where your parents a rich people
are bad people I want to know why
they're saying it so I want to know why
rich people say poor people are lazy and
why are poor people saying which people
are greedy I want both arguments if I
only take one argument I'm naive so I'm
giving you the second argument of school
and the number one book I'm recommending
to you is a book called dropout and get
school I literally just published this
last week think January 25th a book out
published and we've gotten thousands of
emails about this book it's created a
lot of heat and controversy around the
world not just in America it's a simple
book to read it is not a long book
there's like a hundred forty some pages
130 some pages and it answers the
following questions for you number one
is why do we go to college in the first
place no one even asked that question
why do you go to college number two
who should go to college one who should
number three can I succeed and do great
things without college number four
why does tuition and textbooks cost as
much as they do number five
how colleges that simply become a big
tax-free business and number six are the
subjects taught in college sufficient
for life or do we need an upgrade right
this book is specifically dedicated to
all the teenage entrepreneurs and young
entrepreneurs who are somewhat
conflicted and confused
what do I do I'm 14 years old I'm in
10th grade I'm in ninth grade do I go to
college I'm a senior do I go to college
or not this align answer the questions
and I will tell you one thing here as
well the moment you read this book mark
my word you're going to share with your
friends your family your teachers I
challenge you to give it to people who
would disagree with this to give you
their argument that's what I would
challenge you to do read it first and go
to every single one of your teachers and
say have you read this book yet it's
causing a ton of havoc I need you to
read it and give me your feedback
because I'm truly thinking about
dropping out of college dropping out of
high school not going to college after
high school should I or should I not and
let them give you the argument let your
parents give you the argument on the
book here so this will give you clarity
and that's why I put drop out and get
schooled first place now some may say
pad you put chose your own book at first
which I did and the reason why I did is
because everything in life I was what
would we dispense weekend we were at the
fort where we had 3,000 of our agents
came and had magic James Magic Johnson
as one of our keynote speakers he came I
interviewed and then we got on a private
jet I took 18 of our friends to Vegas we
went had a good time during Vegas we
watch Tiesto and then we came back the
following that we stayed at the Palms
executive of what he called it that
would equate the old Playboy penthouse
it's a beautiful place you go on the
pool you come out it's like a drop you
look down elevators in the pan huh it's
a beautiful place and somebody asked me
the question and they say Pat if you
have to say number one thing for
successful would it be I said clarity
clarity all this other stuff is fine
that person can be very innovative but
naughty clear about their lives a person
can be very systematic in duplicatable
but they know no other went out of their
lives a person can have a lot of
discipline but they're still not clear a
person can be long-term thinking but
they're still not clear what like they
want to thank or build a person can be
good straight - straight inspiration and
like you still are not clear about what
you want to do with your life and at
your age
the sooner you can get clarity the
sooner you have an edge on everybody oh
so these are the ten books this is a
challenge I want to give to you here on
this video at the moment the moment you
finish any one of the books you ordered
you finish any one of the books and any
time you read a book post a review on
Amazon no matter which one limit it just
make that a habit because you can always
go back and see which books you read on
what you thought about them from way up
you track in your mind the moment you
poster of the Amazon allows you to read
all your reviews the moment you finish
the book can post a review send me a
snap my snap should be right here
stay David 19 send me a snap and let me
know what you got out of the book and it
will take it from that bottle if you
have any other books that you would add
to this list comment on the bottom
probably that me said throw me the
pillow a quick throw me the pillow real
quick alright
right handed our goal is to get two
million subs by the end of the year if
you haven't subscribed to this channel
yet click on the bottom button here to
subscribe and the alert button is right
next we be one the first to get alerts
every time a new video comes up we are
the number one channel on YouTube for
how-to entrepreneurial videos no one's
in what we're doing I put our stuff
against anybody else and I can tell you
one thing here you can go to college if
I could take 100 kids and 100 and go to
college and the other 100 watch 100% all
the videos of my team and I'm willing to
bet my mom my money on these guys are
going to out-earn these guys is what I'm
willing to put they can go get the
four-year degrees these guys can watch
100 percent of value statement videos
and comment on them they will out earn
these 100 kids that go to college you
don't believe me take up the challenge
go watch all the videos and see what
happens to your mind and how you talk
how you think how you walk without being
said thanks for watching everybody take
care bye bye
you
[Music]